it's easier to skate than walk because
you push it we push with one foot and
you stand on the other one you don't
have to keep moving your feet all the
time but yeah skating is it well it's
it's just fun my name is Yvonne Yvonne
Marie Broder's Talan I was born July 5th
1925 is that right
7-5 25 I'm now 90 and I've been skating
as long as I've been had a pair of
skates my father worked for AT&T yeah
old-fashioned American telephone
telegraph company and then they
transferred him to Denver where we have
stayed forever he was working so hard
and he was so dedicated the doctor told
him he had to have some recreation so
the family went to Evergreen and the
lake we would go up and you could skate
outside my youth was great it once was
the time that somebody would come up
we'll try this well okay we'll try that
oh oh yeah that was pretty good try this
well that was okay then well jump oh
well okay well gee I didn't like that I
fell down
[Laughter]
after a little while I became good
enough and I was able to escape in
competitions and one thing another and I
went met some people who were in a show
in Dallas so I went down and I tried out
for it and I was the right height and
the right size and I was one of ten and
I was one of the one of the girls in the
show and I don't remember what but we
all did something and we got paid but I
loved being in the show and I enjoyed
what what we did I enjoyed it whole time
I was there for many years
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
life just seemed to go on you know
things happen to me I was sick I was
better I got married I had children
you're your life I don't know I I guess
some people can direct their lives but I
kind of just let mine happen
[Music]
well a couple years ago and I was
downstairs and I was trying to pour
myself a cup of coffee and I poured the
coffee and I couldn't drink it and I
went upstairs and I said sherry I I was
trying to say I can't I can't drink my
coffee I can't I can't my mouth won't
work and so she looked at me and she
said get dressed we're going to the
hospital you're having a stroke they
kept me in the hospital for a couple of
days and then I went to a recovery sort
of thing and whenever you have something
that interrupts your regular living it's
so easy to say oh I could do this once I
could do this I could do this and no I
can't now but I will try and so I I've
been working at it and it takes a while
it takes a long time and maybe I'm just
not as good as I watch was probably not
because I could do a lot of things when
I was better and I younger and of course
I think age has something to do with it
too but I like going to the rink and I
like skating and I at anytime I can go
to the rink I go I try and go at least
five days a week and I skate quite a bit
and I'd like to be skating for as long
as I can skate somebody said well now
can how can you skate so well you tipple
when you walk well like tipple when I
walk but I don't have edges on my shoes
I have edges on my skates
getting on my skates so I don't fall
down very much I haven't felt I haven't
followed that many times like me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you do with your life
and what you find enjoyable with your
life is up to you and I think it's
wonderful if you can follow things that
you like to do in your life I like
waking up in the morning because I know
I have another day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]